et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
le blanchemaison bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
à quelle logique ce projet de gazoduc
répond-t-il enfin ce projet répond à la
logique économique mais évidemment il a
des retombées géopolitique le premier
north stream 1 fonctionne et fonctionne
très bien à la satisfaction de tout le
monde et c'est dans ces conditions qu'il
avait été décidé de doubler ce gazoduc
sous la baltique est de construire north
stream 2 alors en effet ce projet
concerne quand même surtout l'allemagne
puisque c'est l'allemagne qui importe
40% de ses besoins en gaz naturel de la
russie
mais c'est une tradition et l'allemagne
a toujours eu de bons rapports avec
gazprom s'était même le cas à l'époque
de l'union soviétique donc d'autres pays
sont embarqués dans ce projet d'ailleurs
une entreprise français qui s'appelle
angie et d'autres entreprises d'autres
pays de l'union européenne
c'est donc un projet économique mais il
a des retombées géopolitique d'abord
dans les relations entre l'allemagne et
la russie on le voit bien
si l'allemagne devait abandonner ce
projet évidemment cela détériorerait
considérablement si relations avec la
russie alors que la russie est un
partenaire économique tout à fait
important pour l'allemagne pour les
entreprises allemandes
sept des conséquences aussi géopolitique
pour les relations entre l'allemagne et
l'amérique puisque monsieur trump a
promis le sanctionner toutes les
entreprises qui participeraient à ce
projet nord stream 2 et que pendant le
nom de maison
ça ne serait pas pourquoi justement pour
quelles raisons les états unis sont ils
opposés les alors restons traditionnels
qu'il arrive en géopolitique pour ne pas
laisser l'europe devenir trop dépendante
du gaz russe mais s'est ajoutée à cette
raisons géopolitiques d'abord également
la raison évidemment de l'ukraine ça va
savoir que l'ukraine prélève des droites
de transit sur le le pétrole le gaz
transit par son territoire
un accord vient d'ailleurs d'être signé
en janvier dernier entre la russie et
l'ukraine
pour prolonger l'accord qui prévoit ses
droits de transit pendant cinq ans mais
à cela s'est ajouté évidemment monsieur
trump qui lui veut vendre son gaz de
schiste puisque maintenant les états
unis sont excédentaires en gaz de
schiste il faut le vendre
or se garde évidemment revient plus cher
puisqu'il faut le liquéfier avant de
charger sur un méthanier pour traverser
l'atlantique et ensuite leur gaz et est
fier à son arrivée en europe il est donc
plus cher cela dit les européens
achètent aussi du gaz liquéfié américain
mais il est logique qu'ils achètent
davantage de gaz russe et qu'il y ait
des infrastructures fixes comme ses
gazoducs alors l'allemagne elle at elle
pris position les autres pays européens
risquent de s'aligner sur sa décision
n'ont pour le moment la chancelière a
dit qu' évidemment d'affaires d'1 valley
risque est de l'amener à réfléchir à ce
projet et la première ministre du
danemark a dit jeu payet aujourd'hui que
en effet il fallait réfléchir il fallait
rediscuter sur ce projet alors je ne
sais pas quelle sera la décision ultime
de l'allemagne mais évidemment les états
membres sont divisés sur ce sujet les
pays baltes et la pologne souhaite que
ce projet ne se passe pas de même que le
danemark et quelques autres et puis à
pays comme on vient de le voir
l'autriche souhaite qu'il se fasse et
qu'on est avis aucun rapport entre un
gazoduc est une affaire de droits de
l'homme d'empoisonnement de monsieur la
vanille justement comment cette affaire
alexeï navalni se retrouve-t-elle
aujourd'hui au coeur du projet north
stream
si les choses se terminent mal c'est à
dire par la mort du projet nord stream
on dira que c'était comme dans la
tragédie grecque lv unité de lieu tous
passés à berlin monsieur n'à van ly est
en convalescence à berlin à votre
travail très soigné par les médecins
allemands et madame merkel à berlin
décidera du sort de nord stream 2 mais
en réalité on voit bien qu'il n'y a
aucun rapport entre les deux choses et
que si il s'avère en effet que monsieur
navalni a été empoisonné par d'une rude
choc
il faut certainement saisir
l'organisation sur l'interdiction des
armes chimiques puisque toutes les armes
chimiques
interdit notamment le novice choc essayé
d'innover de choc qui se promène dans
les mains de divers institutions divers
d'individus il faut le savoir et il faut
que l'organisation internationale pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques
puisse s'en saisir et faire son enquête
avec les autorités russes bien entendu
et puisque monsieur navali et à berlin
il peut sans doute concourir à cette
enquête
il pourrait aussi peut-être dire à ses
autres d'allemands ce qu'il pense du
projet north stream
je ne suis pas du tout sûr qu'il soit
opposé à ce projet merci beaucoup claude
blanchemaison je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales